автомобілі Mercedes можна побачити на
вулицях практично в усіх куточках світу
Ці моделі зійшли з конвеєрів ще минулого
століття Але досі на ходу авто зроблені
на десятиліття
понад 1 мільйон кілометрів їй майже 30
років
знаєте що дістанетеся до місця
призначення без проблем
це автомобіль наче каже вам я можу тричі
об'їхати навколо земної кулі і при цьому
лишитися найкращим це унікально
що ж робить автомобіль Mercedes таким
витривалим
це скорочення до найнеобхіднішого вже
тоді було революційним
конструктори Mercedes прагнули досягти
максимально можливого рівня якості
секрет у простоті чим простіше тим краще
завжди можна все ще спростити
Том Фішер фахівець із реставрації
старовинних автомобілів щороку він
ставить свою роботу на паузу аби
вирушити в експедицію до Африки у
поїздку бере своїх вірних сталевих
друзів моделі Мерседес який випустили в
період з 1968 до 1997 року
хобі моїм другим життям Взимку я їздив
сюди з Європи зі своєю майстерні до
Західної Африки через Марокко чи
мавританію навіть якщо я їду через
сахару і на велику відстань То знає що
доїду до кінцевого пункту призначення
[музика]
Mercedes
що робить їх такими надійними та
витривалими
та триває від самого початку існування
бренду Мерседес їхнього розуміння якості
особливо у штутгарті та його околицях
чому ж тут гарт тому що саме там у 1886
році Карл Бенц випустив перший у світі
автомобіль навіть нині гості Німецького
міста айнбек можуть здивуватися
побачивши на дорогах mercedes-benz який
був свідком зародження автомобільної ери
і який досі находив
цей найстарший автомобіль у Європі
продовжує вражати також і сучасне
покоління інженерів
ці деталі такі старі але ще працюють з
технічної точки зору авто не могло
розвалитися бо концепція двигуна
залишилася незмінною І донині двигун
працював 117 років тому і продовжує
працювати сьогодні приголомшливо плюс
технічне виконання є дуже точним у той
час Вони не поспішали Та не обрізали
вартість
цей досвід втілився у культові моделі
ввести 14 першому Mercedes створеному
для масового ринку разом із наступною
моделлю 115 їх було продано близько 2
мільйонів екземплярів наступним кроком в
еволюції інженерної думки став в 123 у
свою чергу його замінив в 124 що
випускався з
1984-го по 97 роки як його попередники
він вважається втіленням довговічності
це можуть підтвердити таксисти такі як
луан Ніна в Албанії який проїхав Понад
мільйон кілометрів на початку 80-х Пітер
файфер розробив наступне покоління
Здавалося б найвитривалішого автомобіля
[музика]
як видно на прикладі W124 туризм
перфекціонізм був ключовим моментом
в 124 спочатку був абсолютно так би
мовити чистим зведеним до
найнеобхіднішого
будьте простіше настільки простими
наскільки це можливо інженерія не
обмежується жодними кілометрами авто
зроблені краще ніж мали бути або могли
бути
у той час інженери Мерседес вважали за
честь працювати на найстарішого у світі
виробника авто і прагнули створити
найкращий автомобіль на планеті
Маріо Тайсон із міжнародної Федерації
історичних транспортних засобів оглянув
безліч автомобілів для нього німецька
якість заслуга німецьких інженерів
50 років тому маркетинг не грав великою
ролі у прийнятті рішень щодо виробництва
продукції
тому саме інженер з науково-дослідної та
виробничої частини визначали асортимент
та планування продукції
Насамперед вони звертали увагу на гарну
якість проектування
результат неперевершеної інженерної
думки Мерседеси створені в десятиліття
тому штутгарті і досі працюють працюють
і працюють
У деяких частинах Африки наприклад де
люди не поспішають відправляти
автомобілі назвалище термін служби
Мерседес здається ледь не вічним
не тільки якість автомобіля дуже висока
але і метод ремонту цих автомобілів
досить простий тому що більшість
компонентів просто механічні
для Берлінського дилера старовинних
автомобілів бурк гардаштейнса ремонт
таких моделей як Mercedes W124 саме
задоволення
[музика]
Як бачите моторний відсік Не такий вже й
заповнений тут лише механіка ви можете
працювати з простими інструментами для
ремонту із криви можете видалити за
кілька хвилин
у вас тут двигун без Турбо без
будь-якого наддуву компресорів чи ще
чогось
оглянувши детальніше бачимо що сі таке ж
міцне як і двигун
у машині все габаритне що стосується
механіки Наприклад тут є підшипники ви
бачите їх також і на передній осі все
дуже важке
підшипники Більше ніж треба у цьому
полягає концепція автомобіля взяти
найкращий матеріал який тільки можна
знайти і межа можливостей його
використання закладена у конструкції цих
автомобілів
[музика]
досі модель 124 була вершиною
майстерності в лінії Мерседес щодо
якості після неї якість впала
наприкінці
1990-х років керівництво mercedes-benz
ухвалило рішення про серйозні зміни
[музика]
інженерні розробки були обмежені
керівництвом конкуренція ставала все
більшою і всі супутні бренди заробляли
набагато більше грошей
менеджери опинилися в ситуації коли вони
мали приносити більше грошей акціонерам
[музика]
на якості технологій виробництва
попередні постачальники були витіснені
аби можна було здешевити виробництво
Якщо ви тиснете на постачальника ви не
отримаєте такої самої якості як раніше
і звичайно ж сучасні моделі оснащуються
все більшою кількістю електроніки що не
найкращим чином позначається на їхній
надійності
[музика]
сучасні автомобілі які випускаються
зараз підуть У брухт через 15 або
максимум 20 років інша річ Ці машини
ними можна їздити вічно
як це і роблять водії від Албанії до
Африки та інших країн
вони безумовно цінують свої старі моделі
Mercedes
автомобілі створені для вічного
використання і виготовлені